we're doing the book tour and all of a
sudden I get this email that the
Huffington Post is saying that George W
Bush plagiarized some of his book
talking about because I knew that he and
a former speechwriter had worked on all
of it together so I read it oh my gosh
so this reporter for Huffington Post
wrote that in bob woodward's book from
like three times three years ago there's
a passage in there in which bob woodward
quotes somebody who was a source close
to the president who said this about the
iraq war and therefore they said that
that decision points that therefore he
was plagiarizing Bob Woodward and I was
like obviously he's the source close to
the president is the president you
dumbass sorry can we say that on here I
[Music]
remember during the Iraq war and you
being up there and all the things I
lived on the Upper West of New York City
the most liberal place on earth and you
know outside Zabar's they'd have the
book tables and every book was george w
bush's the devil and evil and all of
that stuff we're now the media because
he's not Trump they sort of treat him
like a nice guy he's also a little older
he paints now so they he's kind of good
now and Trump is the ultimate evil do
you see that sort of always churning
through like every ten years where the
media takes someone they hate now
they're good because they have a new bad
guy and that these pieces will always
sort of shift around I have a great
story for you about that Marlin
Fitzwater
was the press secretary for Ronald
Reagan and George HW Bush so for eight
years he was a press secretary for eight
years I joke with him that's a long but
he told me that well actually I invited
him to my house in October of 2008 I
invited all of my staff from the press
room I made them all read his book one
of the best books ever
written in Washington DC as a memoir is
called called a briefing by Marlin
Fitzwater it's fantastic his
storytelling is spectacular so he came
and we had a little book club and he
delivered a message to all of us and he
said you know I know you're feeling like
your boss is really being dragged
through the mud our approval ratings
were terrible this is right after the
financial crisis as you can imagine and
he said let me tell you a story about in
1992 and January 92 they had lost or 93
they had lost to Bill Clinton and he
said it was so mortifying to lose to
Bill Clinton and he said when we left
that day he said I had my head was
hanging so low because I thought no one
will ever ever understand and see what a
great man George HW Bush was well that
changed you know time it has a way of
changing perspective and 43 used to say
when I would prep him for interviews
toward the end I said sir they're gonna
ask you what you think your legacy is
going to be and he said look you know
last year I read three books about
George Washington and if historians are
so analyzing the first president then
the forty-third doesn't have a lot to
worry about
and he would point out that Abraham
Lincoln died thinking that the country
thought he was a failure so yes I think
that the fact that 43 could help me lift
my gaze from current crisis and current
feelings and lift my gaze and understand
there's a longer view and that really
helped me in my life actually overall
not just in politics yeah I love that
can you talk a little bit about just
generally what it's like sort of working
at Fox and being in the the eye of the
storm where often you guys are as
critiqued as the politicians you're
supposed to be talking about and I and
this is a particularly unique thing to
Fox where every given day we know that
Media Matters is watching you guys
waiting for you
to stumble over some word then they clip
that video they get it out to HuffPo
they get it to Vox they try it you know
they lie about timelines Greg's dealing
with a version of this right now related
to coronavirus how in a weird way the
stories then become about you or that
you know somebody's boycotting Tucker on
any given day just that that whole thing
so I have a ton of respect for the media
relations department at Fox News because
they are dealing with a they are
drinking from a firehose every single
day and we have strong personalities at
the network and we have the freedom to
say what we want to say I'm usually
pretty left pretty much left alone I
guess maybe I don't say anything that
controversial are interesting for for
them to bother but I don't like it when
someone who is expressing an opinion and
then gets it gets distorted I really
can't stand that and this is an example
that I wanted to mention it just came to
mind it doesn't have exactly to do with
Fox but it's a good example of my
experience of dealing with the media and
you mentioned the Huffington Post so I
did the PR for george w bush's memoir
decision points when it came out in 2010
and we're out there the book is launched
going pretty well although 43 boy he had
not done interviews in two years and he
was not excited to see the press again
I'll tell you that I bet what he really
you know often presidents disappear for
a little while but he sort of he really
just went under the radar finally there
was that picture of him painting like oh
what happened yeah he said for a long
time he said I don't seek the klieg
lights I don't want this attention and
he knew that there was another chapter
and that he had watched his dad be such
a gracious former president and that's
that was his role model but back to the
book tour so we're during the book tour
and all of a sudden I get this email
that the Huffington Post is saying that
George W Bush plagiarized some of his
book talking about because I knew that
he and a former speechwriter had worked
on all of it together
I believe so I read it oh my gosh
so this
for Huffington Post wrote that in Bob
Woodward's book from like three times
three years ago there's a passage in
there in which Bob Woodward quotes
somebody who was a source close to the
president who said this about the Iraq
war and therefore they said that that
decision points that therefore he was
plagiarizing Bob Woodward and I was like
obviously he's the source close to the
president is the president you dumbass
sorry can you say that on here hey you
can say anything here come on out how
mad I was and it just so happened that
the publisher of the book was also the
publisher of Arianna Huffington's books
so I was getting nowhere with the
reporter to take it down and so she said
that she would call and get her to
handle it and do you know they would not
take it down and so I'm not a stranger
to this behavior and how they treated
him or other conservatives or Trump now
today it's just it's unfortunate but you
just have to work around it yeah but it
must take a certain amount of your
mental stamina during the day right
knowing that these guys are watching you
or even when you're just talking on your
show and yeah you might accidentally say
ass and then you go oh I said that the
guy carrying the alligator with his
mouth taped in the convenience store and
it was during one more thing and I said
what an [ __ ]
and and it caused such an uproar but we
turned it into something funny and
actually the president of the company
got a call from his mom and she said
please don't get mad at Dana don't get
her in any trouble she didn't mean to
sue it's a it was an accident and
besides she was right the guy was an
[ __ ]
he was very go Florida we talked a
little bit about the a little bit about
the the general culture at Fox because
you know until I started going on a
bunch of these shows like a year ago I
don't know I probably thought whatever
may be the mainstream zeitgeist is but I
know that
you know I've been doing your show
basically once a week for a while now
and I go on Greg and Tucker nobody asks
me anything you know the first few times
I went on Tucker they would say oh do
you have some ideas that you want to
talk about but now you guys invite me I
go on we don't discuss anything I know
that I could say anything in those few
minutes and you you may not agree with
me but you'd be okay with it and we can
joke around in the rest of it and people
always say to me well Dave why don't you
go on CNN and MSNBC and I'm like well
they don't invite me what's a good yeah
well well I guess what's the point also
nobody's watching but but you know they
don't invite me I can't just show up
that I actually have a point if you see
you're not going to be allowed to just
be yourself and express your views and
have that respected yeah but but the
meme would be Oh Fox News is just
pushing out talking points to everybody
but I just know it's not true because
you guys let me say whatever I want yeah
I've been there since April of oh nine
I've never once been asked to say
something impress a message anything and
this has never happened to me or to
anybody that I know and I think one of
the best things about box it's a culture
of respecting everybody as an individual
but working as a very close knit team if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell